[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres l'art graphique à la cote
depuis plusieurs décennies comme en
témoigne et succès en librairie de la
bande dessinée ou les succès d'affluence
des grandes expositions mais qui dit
gloire qui dit succès dit aussi débat
polémique même si on peut considérer que
au fond les polémiques sont nés avec la
moderne lui-même et c'est ça dont nous
allons parler notamment ce soir de là
est-ce que là un peu encore représenter
le monde et nous allons le faire avec
deux invités
choisis l'un est un amateur éclairé et
l'autre est un professionnel consacré le
professionnel consacré c'est vous Johan
bonsoir johansort
vous êtes une star de la bande dessinée
et vous êtes un auteur prolixe un
polygraphe même très talentueux et très
original mais vous êtes un jeune
cinquantenaire et vous avez publié déjà
une centaine d'albums réalisés deux ou
trois films
presque autant écrit presque autant de
romans et reçu toute une série de prix
dont quelques César et vous publiez la
synagogue aux éditions d'argot qui
raconte notamment votre jeunesse à Nice
et publier un seul livre c'est pas
possible donc vous en publiez un
deuxième en même temps la fin des
catastrophes chez Dargo qui sont qui est
le recueil de vos dessins de presse dans
Paris Match on va revenir sur tout ça et
l'amateur éclairé c'est Guillaume Durand
bonsoir Guillaume bonsoir à tous
Guillaume aussi vous êtes une star une
vedette mais de la télévision et de la
radio journaliste animateur Europe 1 la
5 TF1 canal et puis maintenant vous êtes
le matin allié et le patron de Radio
Classique mais c'est pas du tout de ça
dont on va parler avec vous on va parler
de votre amour de l'art et notamment de
l'art contemporain parce que vous
publiez des genoux sur l'herbe aux
éditions bouquins qui a d'ailleurs reçu
le prix Renaudot de l'essai et oui et
qui est une promenade tous au frais
alternative dans votre passion pour
l'art contemporain vous vous écrivez à
Sceaux et à gambad comme dit Montaigne
des associations des anecdotes vous vous
racontez la vie des peintres que vous
aimez notamment Manet on va y revenir et
puis à partir de là vous tirez le fil et
vous allez vers d'autres artistes que
vous admirez aussi et qui admire Manet
mais vous parlez aussi de vous de la
maladie que vous allez traverser et qui
crée d'ailleurs une fraternité avec
Manet qui était rongée par la maladie et
puis on va commencer par là vous parler
de vos parents parce que ce sont vos
parents qui vous ont donné le virus si
j'ose dire vous les décrivez de manière
très charmante et notamment votre père
une espèce de dandy d'esthète
désintéressé de l'argent mais passionné
de l'art et la prière c'était la
première je me dis la Frédéric il y
avait pas d'argent et les gens qui
s'intéressaient à l'art il parlait pas
du tout d'art contemporain alors tout
court était une minorité totale
et donc par exemple César qui était le
plus vieil étudiant des Beaux-Arts comme
mon père a explosé pour la première fois
c'était vraiment un voisinage du côté de
la rue Mazarine il est descendu des
Beaux-Arts il est tombé sur papa à Dudu
et et l'aventure a commencé comme ça
après mon père est allé au salon maigre
les premières compressions les gens ont
poussé du hurlement et maintenant vous
avez des compressions de César au MoMA
donc c'est une aventure en fait qu'il a
incarné mais qui n'a aucun rapport avec
le monde de l'art d'aujourd'hui parce
que c'était des gens charmants
mais tout de même
charmant très charmant adorable mais
surplombante quand même pour vous j'ai
l'impression je fais une hypothèse la
psychanalyse de salon il a fallu
attendre que votre père disparaisse à
100 ans presque l'âge de soulage pour
que vous vous sentiez autorisé à écrire
ce livre que vous ayez envie de l'écrire
pour lui rendre hommage mais vous sentez
moi mon père je l'adorais comme ma maman
que j'aime beaucoup essayer de me
regarder la salut et moi je me tape un
cancer de la mâchoire
sans le voir venir du tout donc je me
retrouve au bord de la Bible en fait
et
j'ai le sentiment de la dette et je
souffre un chirurgien génial me donne
des mois pour survivre et je me dis
cette dette en dehors des livres que
j'avais écrit avant comme Yann beaucoup
moins nombreux et elle se voit d'être
payée parce que moi j'appartiens pas du
tout à la catégorie respectable des gens
qui détestent en famille tradition juive
ou même un point commun on va revenir à
ça
mes parents avaient plein de défauts
comme moi j'ai plein de défauts avec mes
enfants mais je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est que je trouve n'ont pas
inacceptable parce que c'est un jugement
moral mais esthétiquement je prendrai ça
ne sert à rien de déglinguer ses parents
pour essayer d'exister si vous voulez et
donc quand il est mort et quand moi j'ai
vu arriver la mort au bout de la rue je
me suis dit il est temps d'expliquer
ou plus grand public possible
ce que c'est que l'art moderne je dis
pas contemporain puisque je dis claire
contemporain n'existe pas et la figure
tutélaire de tout ça c'est noir Manet
c'est un homme qui a tout changé voilà
c'est le cœur c'est le centre c'est le
point de départ mais aussi le centre du
livre vous considérez que Manet c'est
une association j'allais le dire avec
d'autres après d'autres après
Foucault et avant lui après Bourdieu et
avant eux avant après Malraux vous
considérez que Manet et l'homme qui a
fondé la possibilité au fond pour la
peinture de quitter le chemin de la
représentation il faut raconter un
minimum les choses Manet est un grand
bourgeois qui fait un bras d'honneur à
son père en lui disant je ne veux pas
être comme toi directeur du ministère de
la Justice je ne veux pas faire l'école
navale je veux être peintre bon c'est un
grand bourgeois de gauche disons pour
l'époque c'est à dire que République
voilà c'est le terme exact donc il a des
convictions mais il se considère comme
un classique il va chez Thomas couture
qui était le roi des pompiers ou des
artistes de l'époque comme Meissonier
les autres qui a enseigné un art disons
néoclassique donc il prend tout est
technique pendant 6 ans que ça m'a
couture enseignée et après il dit bye
bye l'époque
comme disait Picasso est-ce qu'il faut
c'est trouver la sortie et donc le
dessin préparatif pour les tableaux on
arrête la perspective on la met en jeu
le noir et blanc que Newton avait écarté
à l'époque vous savez quand il avait
étudié les arcs-en-ciel donc le plus
grand scientifique de l'air moderne le
noir et blanc qui va faire le triomphe
du 20e siècle de Guernica en passant par
Malévitch les autres il faut introduire
massivement et Manet fait tout ça en
même temps plus la provocation plus la
tension sexuelle plus l'ambiguïté de la
sexualité parce que par exemple vous
l'avez là le livre
c'est quand même un livre où vous avez à
la fois son beau-frère la femme de Zola
et son frère pour un pour un tableau qui
avant de s'appeler sur Lab c'est
s'appelait la partie carrée avec la
connotation sexuelle voilà Johan vous
partagez la passion de de de de
Guillaume pour Manet ou bien
césane de gamme Monet Courbet pour
prendre des contemporains vous parle
autant que que Manet enfin ce que vous
dites il y a une porte d'entrée dans la
modernité et il y a la question qu'on se
pose aujourd'hui de la pertinence de
l'art aujourd'hui par rapport aux autres
médias c'est-à-dire qu'on va pouvoir
faire l'exposition la plus
extraordinaire est-ce qu'elle sera
marquante face au rouleau compresseur
des réseaux sociaux nous a donc moi la
question qui m'intéresse c'est que peut
faire un artiste aujourd'hui pour être
audible et pour avoir la pertinence qui
avait oui dans ce grand réveil
d'ailleurs c'est un des éléments de de
Guillaume parce qu'à partir de Manet
vous tirer le fil et vous vous décrivez
un certain nombre d'artistes que vous
aimez Monory Nikita
il se trouve à un moment commun aux
artistes sauf exception ils sont
quasiment tous figuratifs
c'est pas enfin vous avez quand même
vous avez quand même une prédilection
dans les choix que j'ai fait il y a non
c'est que j'ai j'étais malade donc il a
fallu que je m'arrête à un moment quand
j'ai fait la la la les pour LVMH une
collection d'entretien avec les plus
grands artistes Yvan il a fallu que je
m'arrête et dans le livre aussi il a
fallu que je m'arrête
mais il y a une chose qui résonnait que
ce soit chez Kunz clavier qui est
complètement abstrait ou d'autres c'est
qu'à chaque fois il me parlait de Manet
de ce n'est qu'après je vois des gens
qui venaient d'univers très différents
cello ça devient du Portugal
kunset américain Robert Songo était
américain George Rondeau est américain
cap pour il est anglais
soulage il est français et à chaque fois
dans la conversation au bout de cinq
minutes il y avait même or Manet quand
vous regardez sur Google il y aura de
parler tout à l'heure des réseaux
sociaux quand on demande aux gens quels
sont les 10 plus grands peintres de
l'histoire il n'est jamais dans la liste
d'indice c'est toujours monnaie Léonard
de Vinci même Frida Kahlo etc etc est-ce
qu'il y a une sorte de discrétion si ce
personnage extravagant qui n'a fait que
d'études suffisamment le déjeuner sur
l'herbe c'est aussi célèbre
Olympia la femme au perroquet le fils
etc mais en même temps lui il est comme
si c'est comme s'il avait disparu quoi
est-ce que vous comprenez tout de même
ce que vous vous faites l'éloge de de
peintre contemporains est-ce que vous
comprenez et vous gralliez les esprits
forts qui vomissent la contemporain ou
la peinture d'aujourd'hui
qu'on puisse même si vous dites que la
provocation et la transgression fait
partie intégrante de toute l'histoire de
l'art mais est-ce que vous comprenez
tout de même que on puisse considérer
que pour prendre des exemples canoniques
coller une banane sur un mur ou
recueillir ses excréments dans une boîte
de conserve c'est pas exactement la même
chose que peindre l'Olympia de Manet ou
pas comme je considère que l'art
contemporain n'existe pas sauf les ceux
qui le détestent
il y a aucune rapport entre les gens qui
pratiquent un article conceptuel
d'autres qui font des monochromes et des
choses qui sont contemporaines il y a
aucun rapport entre soulage qui meurt à
100 ans et qui a mis en haut qui est
jeune actuellement ou d'autres artistes
comme claire tabouret ils sont pas de la
même génération
Yoann par exemple il n'est pas la même
génération de soulage et pourtant ce
sont deux artistes n'ont pas les appeler
les artistes contemporains Yoann n'est
pas j'ai un énorme respect pour son
travail je vais pas le traiter
d'artistes contemporain et l'enferme
dans une boîte dans une armoire c'est
lui point donc c'est déjà un concept qui
n'existe pas qui était commode à
l'époque parce qu'on rangeait les gens
de la prière et aux États-Unis s'appelle
postworth ça s'appelle pas à
contemporain
donc ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il y a comme
partout les bons et les mauvais il y a
des gens qui explorent des filières qui
peuvent paraître
complexes ou du foutage de gueule y
compris pour Samper qui a fait un dessin
célèbre où on voit par exemple un musée
où il y a un tas de charbon et et des
cages au par terre plus des tableaux
abstraits mais c'est son point de vue
sur les choses mais ce qu'il faut pas
c'est que ce point de vue repose tout
est possible dans le domaine de la
critique il faut pas que ce point de vue
repose sur l'ignorance et si vous voulez
il y a quand même par exemple si vous
prenez l'art minimale
je veux bien discuter avec qui que ce
soit de la de la pertinence d'un artiste
mais considéré que dame fleving que seul
Lewis etc sont pas des artistes
importants avec fondation est un truc
ridicule avec que des choses
inaccessibles c'est juste un manque de
connaissances de ce que c'est cette
histoire de l'art d'Américains qui ont
voulu
simplement long une seconde en
l'air la culture
occidentale européenne qui les dominait
faire tout ce que Manet a construit
prenait pendant barre net Newman il
était candidat anarchiste à la mairie de
New York ben les grands tableaux bleus
avec les yeux au mieux lui il a dit nous
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas alors là
c'était la révolte c'est pas comme moi
Johan qui est bon aux parents on ne veut
plus entendre parler de ça il va falloir
qu'on invente quelque chose autrement on
sera toujours une espèce de australpie
le plus puissant du monde on sera
toujours la colonie
et infinie de l'art européen et nous on
en veut pas c'est comme ça que Sony
Newman Jackson Pollock et les autres
c'est-à-dire ils ont dit stop
et il faut le savoir c'est que c'est
délibéré ils ont fait ce choix de
l'abstraction du dripping et de la
colère en fait des genoux sur l'herbe
une promenade je dois dire à ses
enchanter dans l'amour de
l'arc de l'art et à travers lui une
promenade personnelle de Guillaume où on
ne s'ennuie pas et on apprend beaucoup
de choses
Yohan ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas l'observation des artistes
c'est vous vous êtes un artiste vous
observez le monde et donc dans la
synagogue que vous publiez chez Dargo
vous racontez votre jeunesse à Nice mais
vous racontez aussi votre covid et point
commun avec Guillaume la figure
tutélaire de votre père est au centre en
tout cas du début du récit
s'impère auquel vous rendez hommage au
fond par ce livre mais qui a deux
visages d'un côté il est pacifiste
intellectuellement mais personnellement
il est belliqueux il est légaliste c'est
un avocat mais dans la ville essaie de
vous instruire l'autodéronces permanente
il y a eu deux erreurs tragiques dans la
vie de mon père la première c'est qu'il
a cru à la justice donc il a voulu
devenir avocat et la deuxième c'est
qu'il a cru au mérite républicain
puisqu'il a grandi en Algérie dans la
grande pauvreté et il est devenu à Nice
un très grand avocat avec son bateau son
Alfa Romeo donc fort de cette fois
inébranlable il faisait développeurs on
parlerait aujourd'hui de masculinité
toxique il y avait le pacifisme à la
maison et dans la rue quand quelqu'un
l'embêtait il lui tapait dessus en même
temps c'était mon héros parce qu'il a
fait mettre en prison des néonazis c'est
un avocat militant et moi j'essayais de
survivre à la virilité de mon père et à
celle de deux anciens élèves de mon
lycée assez encombrant qui était Joseph
Kessel et Romain Gary donc j'ai dû
développer mes propres systèmes de
défense mais mais on comprend on
comprend ou lisant qui a voulu Finkel
crotte avait écrit le Juif imaginaire et
vous c'est l'anti fasciste imaginaire
parce que vous construisez un personnage
de de héros de la guerre antifascisme il
y a pas de fasciste et les rares que
vous rencontrez sont sympathiques et que
vous prenez de compassion pour eux ça
c'est terrible en fait j'aimais pas
j'aimais pas faire des prières je sais
pas comment c'est dans les autres
religions mais en tout cas c'est juste
c'est long et j'aimais pas la prière à
la synagogue si je disais à mon père j'y
vais plus il m'aurait déshérités puis
était riche en revanche j'ai trouvé le
moyen de monter la garde devant la
synagogue c'est à la suite des attentats
rue des Rosiers rue Copernic et donc
entre l'âge de 16 et de 21 ans j'ai fait
partie des vigiles de la synag de Nice
et c'était une bien piètre résistance
parce que à chaque fois qu'on
rencontrait des néo-nazis en fait
c'était pas des néonazis des petits
bourgeois de Nice qui mettaient une
croix gammée pour déplaire à leur papa
mais enfin c'était difficile de pas s'en
faire des copains ils avaient un
désarroi qui ressemblait beaucoup au
mien donc j'ai jamais réussi à me faire
vraiment d'ennemis je regrette un peu ça
aurait fait de moi le héros de quelque
chose peut-être pour ça que je suis
devenu dessinateur mais justement sans
poursuivre la psychanalyse de salon que
j'avais entrepris avec Guillaume on
comprend quand même on vous lisant que
vous n'êtes pas du tout le bagarreur que
votre père aurait voulu que vous fiez
mais en revanche vous avez perdu votre
mère très jeune et c'est plutôt en fait
du côté de de ça que vous allez parce
que vous êtes rêveur vous êtes
imaginatif vous êtes créatif et on sent
que après avoir essayé vainement de
ressembler à l'homme que votre père
rêvait que vous soyez vous avez plutôt
vous êtes plutôt allé du côté de la
tendresse de la de l'imagination dans
laquelle vous avez dû vous réf j'imagine
en fond compte de la tristesse qui était
là vôtre bien sûr j'ai eu un contrepoid
extraordinaire c'est mon grand-père
maternel donc le père de ma maman qui a
qui est un juif ukrainien qui a été un
grand résistant naturalisé français par
Malraux pour service rendu à la patrie
et qui lui détestait la religion
détestait la guerre détestait la
violence parce que comme médecin
militaire il avait tiré sur les
Allemands et il fallait les raccommoder
le lendemain quand le front avancer donc
il m'a sauvé de mon père parce que lui
dès qu'il voyait un appel à la violence
pour lui c'est un soutenable et c'est
lui qui m'a encouragé à devenir plus
humain peut-être
je reviens un peu à la discussion qu'on
avait avec Guillaume parce que dans dans
la fin des catastrophes vous vous moquez
un peu quand même dans un ou deux
dessins de l'art contemporain vous avez
fait les Beaux-Arts et à la fin des
Beaux-Arts vous avez choisi non pas de
faire de la peinture ou de la sculpture
mais de faire de la bande dessinée
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
d'abord que je trouve vous lui faire des
bandes dessinées et aux Beaux-Arts il y
a 30 ans c'était mal vu aujourd'hui je
suis prof aux Beaux-Arts de Paris et
j'ai pu créer un atelier de bande
dessinée donc non je ne me moque pas je
subis certaines choses j'en apprécie
d'autres et la question est ouverte de
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire comme art
aujourd'hui pour être entendu donc j'ai
pas j'ai pas de réponse définitive
d'Europe centrale et d'Europe de l'Est
qui sont arrivés en France dans les
années 20 pour moi ce sont mes modèles
parce qu'ils ont vu la France comme un
lieu de création de cosmopolitisme et
d'invention et ils ont finalement rendu
sa créativité et son honneur à notre
pays donc d'ailleurs par les formes de
votre dessin par les couleurs on sent
vous êtes rattaché à ce qu'on appelle
l'École de Paris enfin on voit ça vous
inspirez ah oui comme artiste ah oui
pour pour le dessin d'après nature pour
le fait de passer beaucoup de temps dans
la rue et dessiner d'ailleurs dans les
petits dessins que je fais dans dans
Paris Match j'arriverai jamais à la
cheville de 100 p parce que lui avait
une synthèse et une imagination moi ce
sont des choses observées donc moi je
vous offre mes petites promenades dans
Paris j'ai pas de très grandes idées
donc ça reste du dessin d'arpenteur
[Musique]
écrit des romans bon c'est plus qu'une
fois encore vous êtes débordé par votre
imagination vous avez un temps infini
vous dormez peu je sais pas et vous
considérez que c'est pas une discipline
suffisante pour exprimer le monde moi ce
qui me fascine c'est le romanesque au
sens large avec les outils qu'on me
donne donc que ce soit avec des images
ou avec des mots il y a j'ai une passion
dramaturgique en fait c'est moi je me
bats contre le scénario je suis l'avocat
de la permanence tragique j'essaye de
retrouver finalement dans la bande
dessinée il y a une théâtralité on est
dans quelque chose de qui relève presque
plus de l'oralité que du roman et même
quand je fais des romans même quand je
fais des films ce sont les enfants de
mes bandes dessinées donc je suis plus
dans une quête langagière que dans une
recherche formelle parce qu'il y a des
dessinateurs tellement plus fort que moi
et il y en a un qui s'est inspiré des
bandes dessinées c'est Philippe Guston
qui est un immense peintre américain qui
a fait le détour par l'art abstrait qui
est revenu ensuite à une figuration
phénoménal ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'il y a un voisinage et un chemin
entre ses disciplines et que chacun
s'enrichit et d'ailleurs ça commence
parce que le début de tout ça c'est
quand même l'apparition de la
photographie c'est au moment où la
peinture va être confronté à la
photographie et c'est c'est un bah la
question c'est justement de ne plus être
dans l'imitation du réel et de et
j'allais dire de sombrer dans le bon
sens du terme c'est ce que disait Yoann
à propos du romanesque dans une sorte
d'apocalypse des sentiments c'est à dire
que c'est là où est le rendez-vous
et Manet c'est ça puisque on se rend
compte qu'il y a la fois du voyeurisme
un inceste l'histoire de sa famille est
un vrai semblable mais c'est ça qu'on
voit sur les œuvres qui font qu'on a
l'impression d'être face à un Hitchcock
mais juste la maladie et en même temps
on assiste à la pénétration d'ailleurs
Johan en est la preuve vivante la
pénétration du cinéma de la photographie
de la peinture qui désormais s'entremêle
et son père garde les tableaux toute la
journée et kubrique pareil alors le
bonheur des livres c'est le plaisir de
ses lecteurs comme vous le savez donc
chaque semaine on demande un lecteur de
d'expliquer son amour de la littérature
ou d'un des livres et surtout de poser
une question à l'un d'entre vous en
l'occurrence c'est à Johan qu'il va
poser sa question ce lecteur c'est Bryan
et Bryan on vous écoute
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Bryan et donc moi
je suis plutôt un lecteur de tout ce qui
est roman historique me livre d'histoire
ou politique parce que même quand je dis
la littérature j'ai j'aime beaucoup
avoir une trame politique ou ou
historique dans les livres que je lis
donc c'est vraiment beaucoup de
littérature du style lexit Tocqueville
où on est vraiment sur des écritures
politiques le livre que je souhaiterais
recommandé au lecteur c'est et qui
correspond bien à mon profil c'est guère
épais de Tolstoï que j'ai dû récemment
et qui correspond un peu à la
littérature avec une trame historique
donc dans les guerres napoléoniennes en
territoire russe bonjour monsieur Spa
vous parlez beaucoup de
d'extrême droite dans votre livre et
très peu d'extrême gauche pro PA
pourtant vous avouez dans les dernières
pages de votre livre que nous
représentez pas dans votre bouquin
l'étendue des attaques propres
palestiniennes qu'il y a eu contre les
flux en France et même quand on regarde
votre chronologie des apprentisémites
que vous mettez à fond de votre livre
qui ont lieu dans durant votre durant
votre vie on voit que il y a quasiment
autant d'acte 36 et d'extrême gauche et
d'extrême droite donc pourquoi en parler
si peu et aussi ce que vous avez pas
l'impression d'être un peu en décalage
avec ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui étant
donné que même dans votre chronologie on
voit que les derniers attentats
antisémites avaient plutôt une origine
d'extrême gauche
vous avez le cerveau gauche qui est
reformais je tiens tout de même à
rappeler que la
généalogie des actes juives de mon
vivant dans le livre commence par
l'assassinat des athlètes de Munich et
n'oublie pas l'attentat des rues des
rosiers de la rue Copernic simplement
mon livre parle de Nice dans des années
80 il vous a pas échappé on y croiser
davantage de skinhead que de membres du
FPLP c'est tout après je pense que la
haine des Juifs est mon sentiment c'est
que la haine des Juifs et le ciment du
radicalisme religieux et politique d'où
qui viennent vous ne trouverez pas de
radicalisme sans antisémitisme parce que
c'est un fantasme parce que ça fait il y
a une joie à être anti juif et je suis
tout prêt à reconnaître que cette joie
est répandue dans tout le spectre
idéologique et religieux à l'époque
justement de Manet après c'était c'était
une joie qui est quasiment public ça
c'était si on voudrait juste la bataille
on voit les progrès qu'on a fait depuis
parce que désormais c'est prohibé alors
avant de nous quitter comme on peut pas
inviter tous les auteurs on peut tout de
même parler d'un centre de livres qu'on
a lu et aimé et je vais vous demander de
vous livrer à cet exercice mais
attention c'est satisfait ou remboursé
il faut que ce que vous recommandez
plaise vraiment à nos lecteurs donc quel
est le livre dont vous auriez envie
qu'on le lise cette semaine
si vous aimez Frédéric Dard et vous
rêvez d'un frais Riga américain dont les
héros viennent du East Texas jetez-vous
sur Joe Airlines dont les les deux héros
sont des vigiles des gardiens de nuit
qui ont des aventures foireuses à
l'issue desquelles ils sont beaucoup
cassés la figure mais une traversée dans
l'Amérique contemporaine radicale et
très drôle donc joeylan Dale jetez-vous
sur les aventures de happen Léonard
Guillaume moi le dernier livre que j'ai
lu c'était moi crédit de Céline parce
que je l'ai relu je ne m'en souvenais
pas et j'ai été subjugué parce que ça
fait aussi partie de mon projet je pense
qu'il y a quand même des artistes qui
nous dominent et qu'on peut pas entrer
dans un registre qui est tout le temps
celui de tous pareils tous le même
talent c'est pas vrai et quand Céline
écrit au début de mon accrédit je suis
le chef de garde du diabolique vous
dites bon celui-là il y a tous les
défauts de la planète mais il y a une
chose qui est certaine c'est que la
planète il va la mettre par terre et
c'est ce qu'il a fait en 4 ou 5 livres
Catherine Millet ou la connaissez bien
elle est la patronne c'est positif
et elle raconte c'est une série
autobiographique je crois que c'est le
troisième tome dans lequel il se trouve
parce que c'est elle raconte la vie des
galeries dans les années 60 en même
temps que sa vie sexuelle mais elle
parle de vos parents donc je ne vous
l'offre pas je le garde et puis enfin
c'est un beau livre bon ski c'est cet
artiste dont on ne connaît pas
exactement l'identité mais que les
détracteurs de l'art contemporain voient
comme le symptôme puisqu'il est
notamment celui qui fabrique des œuvres
auto-destructrices donc les les les
contenteurs de l'art contemporain
concert que voilà l'art contemporain est
destiné à s'autodétrutruire merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi cette émission est
terminée merci à Yoann Spar merci à
Guillaume Durand l'un est un ami des
artistes et l'autre un ami du journal
puisqu'il est un artiste vous pouvez
merci à Brian notre lecteur et vous
pouvez nous revoir cette émission sur le
site de Public Sénat ou sur vos
plateformes préférées et vous pouvez
aussi nous retrouver la semaine
prochaine
même même chaîne même jour même heure à
moins que d'ici là nous nous soyons
croisés dans une librairie
[Musique]